hey glamour here are some of my top tips
on surviving fashion month with my
favorite brand come in
hi I'm Neelam Gayle and I'm a model
I travel a lot because of my job and
fashion month takes a lot of planning
for me some of the items I can't travel
without oh this jumper I found it on
label mix and it's from g1 and I just
love the color and the fact that it's a
little bit fitted the next thing I can't
travel without is my phone and I
actually have this really cool case so
you can put this around your neck as a
necklace so that way I don't lose it and
it's always on me and safe I always
always always travel in trainers these
ones are actually quite new but as you
can see from these ones most of my
trainers have really really beat up
these camo trousers please feel very
nineties to me and I feel like this is
coming back in fashion now and you can
just wear it with so many different
things
my favorite accessories probably like
jewelry I like layering rings I like
wearing my watch pretty much wherever
I'd go and I'm not fussy about wearing a
certain color like I'll mix gold and
silver together
I would actually say that nanda is my
secret Savior because between church is
so busy and you could just go in there
and you know that your mill is going to
be good it's really quick and easy and
also I always love having Nando's during
Fashion Week because when I've been
traveling obviously nowhere else has it
so really makes me feel like I'm home so
these pieces I've actually selected for
my fashion month wardrobe and they're
from a really cool website could label
mix it's a new site and it hosts loads
of core designers like Jiwon Osman and
Tatum Jones and I think it's amazing
that they're bringing those brands to
this website for everyone to enjoy at a
more affordable price point I really
love this bag it's from AV Robertson it
feels so nice and luxurious but I also
think it's perfect for Fashion Week I
also love these trousers I feel like
it's bringing a sportswear element which
is what I love but they're also a very
cozy fabric that you could wear on a
plane but then again you could dress
this up for an event or for show another
piece I love are these jeans I love that
they're oversized and I think they're
really cool wash and these are by Regina
Pio and I think that it's called it
they're already on the label mix site
because she's doing her first show
during London Fashion Week and I think
it's really important that they're
supporting emerging designers and talent
[Music]
this is a look I would wear to like a
Fashion Week party and cocktails I feel
like it's really luxurious with this
coat and this is something I would wear
while I'm traveling the jeans I really
really love because they're oversized
comfortable but they still look cool
because of the wash of the Jean I mean
bag is by Mimi berry it's just really
perfect you can wear it with anything
this is my off-duty look and it's
actually my favorite look from my
selection it's by the designer Jiwon
it's so comfortable but it's also
something that you can dress up or down
and this is something I'd wear to more
of a formal event and I chose this dress
by Osman because it is formal I'm really
girly and pretty and that's why I
decided to wear these Osman shoes with
it because they're certainly more quirky
this leather jacket is from lab London I
like it because it's really oversized
but also it adds an extra element that
outfit
[Music]